One thing we really recommend in this
program is to try to get into a routine.
When you do on campus classes, you
kind of have the routine provided for
you, you go to class a certain number
of times a week at a certain time.
And that kind of gives you
your routine for that course.
Online though, we don't have that.
So we really recommend that you set
aside a certain time each week to watch
the lectures, a certain time each
week to work on the assignments.
And definitely set aside some time
each week to interact on Piazza with
your TAs, instructors and classmates.
That'll make sure you don't
get into a situation where
halfway into the semester you find out,
I'm way behind on this class and
I'm never going to catch up.